[Music]
foreign
[Music]
director of product management from
Google cloud and I'm joined by my
colleague Jerome Sims I am r
and we're both excited to share with you
some new products and capabilities we're
introducing at next this year as Amar
said I'm Jerome Sims director of product
management at Google and I'm focused on
Google's devops portfolio it's great to
be here with Amar to share these
exciting updates with our devops
assistant men and operator friends now
Amar will kick off the session
thank you Jerome at Google Cloud our
mission is to accelerate every
organization's journey to digitally
transform the business and when it comes
to devops we serve customers of all
sizes and types today
while some of you are early on your
journey some are way ahead of the peers
regardless of where you are on your
devops journey we want to help
let me give you some examples of
Transformations were enabled recently
first Gordon Food Service
this is the largest family operated Food
Distribution Company in North America
with Google Cloud they've been able to
increase the number of deployments from
just four times a year to 2900 times a
year that's a huge jump
and lows America's leading retailer in
Home Improvement I go there every other
weekend
they went from doing just one release
every two weeks to over 20 releases
every single day
or Vodafone which I'm sure most of you
are familiar with one of the world's
leading telecommunication companies they
used our vertex Ai and devops services
to build a cutting-edge AIML platform to
enable Next Generation AI use cases for
their customers as you saw we partner
with companies of all sizes to enable
such transformations
and our goal is to make devops on Google
Cloud easy for your organization as well
and to fulfill this Mission we focus on
four key areas which address the key
challenges we hear from these customers
every day
first is security
in devops has become increasingly
critical and we are seeing more and more
hackers preying on the security
vulnerabilities of your software supply
chain today
software supply chain simply put is a
journey that your software code takes
from development all the way to
production software supply chain attacks
are in a sharp rise in recent years
Gartner predicts that 45 of
organizations worldwide will have
experienced a software supply chain
attack by 2025. number two multi-cloud
more and more organizations are adopting
multi-cloud today for many reasons
including the need for distributed
applications data sovereignty security
compliance
Etc
and your devops teams are being asked to
support such multi-cloud deployments
however this is not easy
how do we ensure efficiency security and
consistency as we develop deliver and
deploy across multiple clouds this
becomes a critical challenge
number three sustainability
given the global climate change
all organizations are rising to the
challenge virtually every team in every
Enterprise today is looking at how it
can help their organization reach their
carbon emission targets
now Google has long been a Pioneer in
achieving sustainability in our internal
operations and now we want to provide
tools to support sustainable development
and operations for all organizations
and finally
integrating and scaling your devops tool
chain
this is still a challenge for many
organizations
a typical devops tool chain can consist
of many open source or commercial
products and span across multiple areas
this can lead to large complex and
fragmented tool chains that are very
difficult to integrate in scale at
Google Cloud we're working diligently on
integrating our devops tool chain
within the broader ecosystem and we also
want to support you to run your devops
tools on Google cloud with ease and
scale
this year we are launching many new
products and capabilities across all of
these four areas and now I'm going to
hand over to my colleague Jerome to tell
you more thanks Amar let's dive into
some details of our announcements today
as Amar just mentioned software supply
chain Securities becoming an
increasingly critical concern for many
devops teams and to help you better
protect your software Supply chains
we're very excited to bring you software
delivery Shield
software delivery Shield is a
comprehensive yet modular set of
capabilities that spans a set of Google
Cloud products delivering a fully
managed end-to-end solution to help
protect your software supply chain it
can start from helping to protect your
applications at the local developer
environment
enhance the security posture of your
software Supply
build a more secure CI CD Pipeline and
finally protect your application once
deployed to production
on top of that we let you establish
maintain and verify a chain of trust
along your supply chain through policy
enforcement
at next this year we're introducing new
capabilities across many of these areas
first shifting all the way left to help
you better secure your applications
during development we are launching
Cloud workstations
a new service which provides a fully
managed local development environment on
Google cloud with built-in security
measures
if you're worried about source code
exfiltration or privacy risks Cloud
workstations allows you to limit access
to sensitive resources or the public
internet or even use a fully private
Gateway if tomorrow you patch a
vulnerability or base image with Cloud
workstations forced image update your
developers will automatically have
updates reflected in their own local
environments the next day
with Cloud workstations you can be much
better off in terms of securing your
local development environments
more than that we are also giving your
developers tools to help them code
faster with greater security
with Cloud code Source protect
developers will get real-time security
feedback as they work in their IDE such
as identification of vulnerable
dependencies and licensing information
this quick and actionable feedback can
allow developers to promptly make
corrections to their code at the
beginning of the software development
process thereby saving hours of time
that would otherwise be spent in costly
future fixes
when your developers are coding in Cloud
workstations artifact registry and
container analysis can give them a
secure space to store and manage their
container images and language packages
and also scan them for vulnerabilities
we are now adding more language support
for vulnerability scanning you can now
do unpush scanning for Maven and go
packages in containers and for
non-containerized Maven packages as well
to help you improve the security of your
open source dependencies our assured
open source software service provides a
trusted source for you to access open
source packages curated and tested by
Google
this service now provides over 250
packages across
Java and python these packages are built
in our own secured pipelines and
regularly scanned analyzed and fuss
tested for vulnerabilities it also
includes verifiable salsa build
provenance
salsa stands for supply chain levels for
software artifacts it is a framework
that brings industry recognized best
practices for software supply chain
integrity
in continuing to help secure your
pipelines I'm really excited to announce
Cloud build our fully managed continuous
integration platform now supports salsa
level 3 bills in addition to providing
an ephemeral and isolated build
environment Cloud build now generates
authenticated and non-falsifiable build
Providence for both containerized
applications and non-containerized Java
packages and also displays security
insights for built applications
finally
to help secure the runtime environment
we're introducing a new set of security
features in gke gke can now help assess
your container security posture and give
you active security guidance it also
includes many out-of-the-box security
capabilities well how about we just take
a look at the demo now
hey everyone and thanks Jerome my name
is Victor Salve I'm a product manager
here at Google cloud and we're going to
take a quick look at a brand new
capability within gke so gke's new
security posture management capability
provides foundational
kubernetes security for your clusters by
analyzing your workloads and this
includes things like configuration
concerns so like your pod spec security
settings it also looks at your images
your running images and scans them for
vulnerabilities on a daily basis
so if I drill into this report I have
all sorts of ways I can slice and dice
so for example I can you know look at it
from a workload perspective namespace so
forth I can even filter by severity
things like my critical and highs and
get a report of just the things that I
want to prioritize and address most
immediately in this case I have a
vulnerability in zlib but it also gives
me specific remediation and that's one
of the things that stands out with
posture management for gke is gives you
direct insights into where these things
are happening in your system so the
affected workloads how to remediate them
and so forth
if I slice this by workload I can
actually look into specific workloads
and see what's affecting them so in this
case there's a number of vulnerabilities
in my Currency Service workload I have
you know configuration concern so I can
go in and actually get specific
remediation instructions directed right
at this particular issue for this
workload so I know how to address it
it's not just a vague concern
and of course I can then just go in and
update it in my pods back and make sure
that I'm running with the best security
possible for my containers and for my
applications
with these many features in gke we're
helping to make security easy for every
customer who is using our fully managed
kubernetes services
for customers on cloud run our
serverless platform we're introducing
new enhancements to Cloud runs security
panel it now displays software supply
chain security insights such as
salsa build level compliance information
build Providence and vulnerabilities
found in running services
when your developers are building
application oftentimes they will need
databases I'm happy to introduce Cloud
SQL security recommender powered by
active to assist
Cloud SQL is the fully managed
relational database from Google cloud
with security recommender it can now
automatically monitor the security
posture of your databases alert you on
potential security vulnerabilities and
also provide guidance to help mitigate
the risks
today more and more devops teams are
being asked to support multi-cloud
deployment
to make multi-cloud easier for you we're
introducing a set of new features to our
anthos platform
anthos is a cloud-centric container
platform to run modern apps anywhere
consistently at scale
with the newly introduced features
anthos customers can now enjoy a unified
management experience everywhere from a
single Google Cloud console
and to drive consistent security
governance and observability across a
fleet of clusters spanning all
environments whether on-prem hybrid or
multi-cloud
in addition ansos now supports VM
deployments for your Edge environments
so customers can modernize their Edge
applications and infrastructure using a
common platform that supports both
containers and VMS sustainability has
been a core value of Google from the
very beginning and to help our customers
develop and operate more sustainably I
am pleased to announce that carbon
footprint is now generally available
carbon footprint introduces a new level
of transparency to support you in
meeting your climate goals now let me
invite my colleague Cynthia to show you
a quick demo of carbon footprint
thanks Veron hi everyone my name is
Cynthia I'm the product manager of
Google Cloud carbon footprint
you can access carbon footprint from the
console navigation under Tools
here you can see the carbon footprint
associated with your gcp usage
we use granular Machine level energy
consumption data coupled with hourly
emissions factors which is then
apportioned to each customer based on
usage
for more details you can see the
emissions broken down into Scopes 1 2
and 3.
all of which are following the
greenhouse gas protocol carbon reporting
and accounting standards you can also
see a monthly Trend chart
together with breakdowns by project
by product
and by region
as Google invests in enough renewable
energy and carbon credits to neutralize
all of our operational greenhouse gas
emissions the net operational emissions
associated with your Google Cloud usage
are also zero
Beyond this dashboard you can also drill
down to the data through scheduling an
export into bigquery
which you can then use to save to Google
Sheets
or to customize your own dashboards
using looker or data Studio
if you have activists enabled from
either the carbon footprint UI or
recommendations Hub you can review the
projects identified as Idle and most
likely unattended through machine
learning
you can choose to shut down or reclaim
these resources which will not only
reduce your carbon footprint but also
help you save costs
with the ga of carbon footprint we
believe it will help organizations
achieve a much Greener operations on
Google Cloud
as previously discussed integrating and
scaling your devops tool chain is a
challenge for many devops teams and for
that I'm happy to announce our managed
service for Prometheus is now ga
it offers a fully managed and easy to
use monitoring service based on open
source Prometheus with the speed and
scale brought to you by Google Cloud
with this service there is no longer a
need to Federate add resources manually
or devote time to maintaining your
monitoring infrastructure you can focus
on scaling your business and not
Prometheus
in addition
to make continuous deployment easier for
you we added integration between Cloud
deploy our fully managed continuous
deployment service and Cloud run are
leading serverless runtime environment
with this integration in place you will
be able to do continuous deployment
through Cloud deploy directly to Cloud
run with one-click approvals and
rollbacks Enterprise security and
built-in delivery metrics
next log information is very useful for
our devops teams and to make the use of
logs easier on Google Cloud I'm excited
to announce log analytics a new feature
of cloud logging through an Innovative
partnership with bigquery Cloud logging
now allows your devops teams to get more
value out of the logs through the power
of SQL queries
having your logs readily accessible in
bigquery you can also leverage
bigquery's Innovative machine learning
for more advanced use cases well
everyone that's everything I have today
our teams work super hard to bring you
all these new products and capabilities
and I hope you're as excited about them
as I am now let me pass it back to Omar
thanks Jerome for sharing those exciting
announcements with us
with these capabilities your
organization can adopt a more secure
intelligent and sustainable devops
practice if you want to learn more and
I'm sure you do we invite you to check
out all the other sessions in the
operate track our subject matter experts
will take you through them in more
detail and last but not least we have
just released the 2022 edition of the
state of devops report you can download
it by scanning this QR code or from the
additional resources section down below
thank you and on behalf of Jerome and I
we hope you have a great next 2022.
[Music]